[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre j'associe à ma
question les amis de la justice et de la
liberté en particulier c'est du groupe
France Arménie le 13 septembre
l'Azerbaïdjan a lancé une nouvelle
offensive contre l'Arménie malgré
l'indifférence presque général c'est
bien une nouvelle guerre de conquête et
d'extermination qui se jouent aux portes
de l'Europe avec son premier lot de
crime de guerre fièrement exhibé sur la
toile par les militaires azerbaïdjanais
ce filmant dans leurs œuvres de viol de
torture de démembrement cette logique
génocidaire cette arménophobie ce
racisme d'État pratiqué par
l'Azerbaïdjan avec le soutien de la
Turquie n'a pas vocation à s'arrêter à
ce pays il y a Malia a d'ailleurs
déclaré vouloir chassé ses chiens
d'Arméniens alors madame la ministre que
comptez-vous faire concrètement pour
éviter que cette part de l'histoire de
l'humanité que ce pays souverain la
République d'Arménie ne